- What's up believe nation?
It's Evan, my one word
is believe and I believe
in people more than they
believe in themselves
and my sincere hope is that if you see
in you what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
I started the Mentor
Me series with the goal
to try to learn from people who have done
a lot more than us, to try to hang out
with people who've had
more success than us
and hopefully some of their beliefs,
some of their mindset, some
of their way of working
seeps into us, to help us
become the best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to
learn from Floyd Mayweather
and Conor McGregor and their motivation.
Also as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired by it as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(inspiring music)
- Do you remember the first time
that the thought of
fighting Floyd Mayweather
crossed your mind?
- Its been on my radar
for a long, long time.
As a young man coming up in the game,
in the sport of MMA,
I was listening to him
in a similar weight class,
similar weight category
speaking ill of the sport, speaking ill
of the discipline, and as
a young kid I'm looking
at him at such a high
level, saying these things
about the sport that
I'm dedicating my entire
life to, and I'm thinking,
"I'll see you for that one day."
- Why are we getting ready to watch
Floyd "Money" Mayweather in the ring
against Conor McGregor August 26th?
- Man, it's what the world demanded.
I put myself in the right position
to make it happen.
So I put myself in the right position,
to make it happen, it's all about chess.
And its not really about
being on the chess board
anymore, it's about
controlling the chess board.
And that's what I was able to do.
- Did you want this
fight, or did you respond
to somebody who wanted you?
- Actually, I asked for the fight.
I think it was kind of mutual.
I think I wanted the fight.
Pretty sure he wanted the fight.
I don't think in the beginning Dana White
thought the fight could happen.
But, we're here now.
- You wanted the fight. Why?
Not just because its
what the people wanted,
I know, I got that answer, but what else?
- Of course. I can put
myself in the position
to make nine figures, why not?
Why not? So I put myself in the position.
- Once again, there
will never be a fighter
that's on my level.
Because you have to be able
to go where I go mentally.
You've got to be on my level mentally.
And it's hard for anyone
to be on my level mentally.
Because I think outside the box.
That's why I'm always doing
record breaking numbers.
record breaking things.
That's why I was able to go
on Dancing With the Stars
and take chances, and
go on WWE and still fans
from the WWE are still fans
from Dancing with the Stars
and take chances, to
become a household name.
To become a pay-per-view star,
to become a mega-superstar,
to have the biggest
deal in sports history.
I roll the dice. I take chances.
- When you hear boxing
aficionados like Max Kellerman
say you're not going to land a punch
how do you react to that.
Like today, we posted videos
of you hitting the bag,
and its all people saying,
"Look how slow he is
he doesn't know what he's doing.
Look at this movement stuff."
Do you enjoy that? Is that better for you?
- It happens to all
greats, training methods.
Everything is criticized.
Originally Floyd, way
back, his method of hitting
the pads and hitting
the bag was ridiculed.
During the Hatten buildup,
what I started seeing
about Floyd, they ridiculed his methods.
And all of a sudden everyone starts trying
to follow his methods.
You know what I mean?
When there's success,
it's been the same with me
when I started incorporating
movement training,
I started incorporating certain attacks,
and certain approaches in
the mixed martial arts game.
Ridiculed, it's a joke, a joker.
How many times have I been
called a joke or a joker?
And then, everyone starts following,
and trying to study,
it's no different here.
The boxing game, oh look he doesn't
move this way, what's he doing,
this that and the other.
They just don't understand,
they don't understand,
they just try and discard it.
But thankfully, August 26th, there can be
no running from it.
The same thing will happen
that always happens.
They will try and push it away,
it will be put in front of them.
Floyd will be slapped,
and then they'll begin
the studying process,
and then the implementing
process, and then I'm on to the next.
- Which is what?
- I'm on to my next wave of preparation.
So they're here, and I'm here again.
And then I'm here, and then I'm here.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- So that's life.
- A man that has never
been in the boxing ring
is in the ring with the best ever.
That's what you describe
yourself as being.
- I don't describe myself, we must realize
men lie, women lie, numbers don't lie.
- 49 and 0.
- Not just 49 and 0,
let's really talk about
Mayweather who didn't broke
every record in boxing.
When we get to talk about highest gate,
even right now they're saying,
"Oh, a Mayweather fight didn't sell out."
You know, when they do sell out, I think
I reached the one,
live gate it reached
like, 80 something million
for this fight, already
we're at 60 something million
though they're saying that Mayweather
is not doing numbers anymore.
As far as taking the less punishment,
I've took less punishment
than any fighter.
Not just best defense,
let's talk about offense.
The most accurate fighter of all time.
On the outside of the ring, it's not just
about being inside of the ring.
I've already conquered that.
I'm even smarter on the outside.
I have to be a genius to
even make a fight like this
happen, so what does that say about me,
for making this fight happen?
- It says that you're a
brilliant businessman,
not just a great boxer.
- And that's what I always spoke about,
that's what I always spoke about.
I get my credit by what I do in the ring.
But I don't get my credit
about what I do on the outside.
- You're enjoying great
riches and success now,
but can you put yourself in the mindset
of the guy who is waiting
in line with other people.
Do you remember what
that guy was thinking?
- Always.
- Were you daydreaming of this?
Was that even possible to daydream?
- Every second of every
day I was daydreaming it.
But of course I can go
back and think there.
I lived there in my head
and I'll always be there.
I show up and walk every single day
like I'm not in the position I'm in.
I'm not me, that's the mindset I'm having.
It's walking.
- You've got fighters
that may be faster than me.
You've got fighters
that may hit harder than me.
You've got fighters that's very athletic.
But you don't have no fighter that
can make adjustments like me.
You don't have fighters that
can be on my level mentally.
It's never personal for me.
It's always business.
Every other fighter
fights for certain things.
Everybody fights for what they fight for.
My thing is this: I keep
my eyes on the prize.
I never focus on things outside the ring.
My focus is the guy that's in front of me.
You get to where you're trying to get to
by staying focused,
staying on a parallel path.
I always had a dream, and my dream
was to be the best.
No matter what happens Saturday,
when it comes down to boxing,
I'm the best at this.
- What do you think they'll say
about you in 50 years?
- You know, I'm not quite sure what
they'll say about me.
They'll probably just say I'm a young kid
who showed up when he said
he was going to show up.
And that's it. I don't know.
I don't really think about that.
- When you walk in here with the...
- What I do know is,
I just know that it will live on.
That's what I do know.
I cannot control what
people say about me now,
or in the future.
But I certainly know what I am doing,
and the stuff that I am doing and achieved
will live on long after I am gone.
- As you've been away from the game
and you reflect on your life
and your career right now,
- Yes.
- Where are you?
Just looking at the life
of Floyd Mayweather.
- Just looking at my life,
I don't think most people could handle
being in my shoes.
Yo, yo!
I don't think, as of right now,
I don't think no one
could handle my situation.
- Why not?
- They just can't.
- What's your situation
that can't be handled?
- I'm just saying that it's like,
they feel like it's pressure on me.
They try to defeat me
in many different ways.
They try to bring up the tax thing,
they try to bring up he's been locked up,
he's arrogant, he's unappreciative.
Years and years and
years they've been trying
their best to defeat me
mentally.
I can't be defeated.
I'm a strong individual.
Nothing can throw me off,
nothing can throw me off
throw me off key.
I'm always focused on what I've got to do.
- And that's going to
be the case August 26th?
- August 26th is going
to be real interesting.
And I'm not backing up.
Remember, I told you that.
- You're not backing up?
- I'm not backing up.
(dramatic music)
- When I was a kid I
always visualized stadiums.
And even when I was playing football
I'd kick the ball against the wall
and pretend I'd scored a goal
and I'd run off and
I'd be raising my hand,
and visualizing an arena full of fans.
And that was something I'd done as a kid
out on my own, just running
around kicking the ball.
I'd always had these visions of something.
I just didn't know what it was.
And I suppose when I came to these events
and started training and came to an event,
I was like, okay,
This is is, this is what I'm going to do.
And now I'm doing it.
- But did you ever have, let's call it
a normal job, Conor, a 9 to 5?
- Yeah, the Irish thing
is to get into a trade
straight away, I was no different.
As soon as I finished school,
I was always getting pestered.
What are you doing with your life?
And this deal and that.
They didn't know what it was.
They didn't know what MMA was.
They didn't know none of this.
They didn't know I could
make a career out of it.
As far as they were concerned,
my ma and da I'm talking about,
as far as they were concerned,
I was just getting into a cage
and fighting with some other guy.
They didn't know nothing about it.
No one did, really.
But I knew.
You know what I mean, I knew.
I ended up getting a trade,
just to keep them quiet.
I always used to have a
lot of fights with my dad.
- What trade did you get?
- I ended up getting a trade as a plumber.
- How bad was that?
- The plumbing?
- Yeah.
- Horrendous.
- Were you actually in the trenches?
- It was in industrial, so I'd be like,
building this, it'd be like the plumbing
that would be needed in a place like this.
6 o'clock in the morning.
I used to have to walk for about an hour
to get there on motorway.
And then I'd stand on
the edge of the motorway
and wait for a bloke to drive by
so he'd give me a lift.
And then the motorway was getting
renovation at the time,
so it would take me
2 hours, 2 and a half hours
to get to the place, it
was out in the country
and I'd be there for ten hours, working.
And I was a first year, so I was the worst
of the worst, I was only a beginner.
Then two hours to get
back in the traffic again.
Which is a horrible, horrible time.
And I was like, you know what,
I don't want to do this,
and then I just left.
I lasted 18 months doing it.
It was tough and it
wasn't the life for me.
And then John said, 'cause I was training
with John as well at the time,
and then John got on Twitch and says,
"I have a show, I'm in a show
and I'd like you to fight in it."
And then that was it.
I just packed it in, didn't show up.
My da used to come in and punch the hell
out of me, try and drag me out of bed,
and I just wouldn't go.
Had an hoopla for a good
few years with him over it.
And that was it, I just
packed it in, quit,
and then focused on training.
I knew what was going to happen.
I knew I was going to
get here, they didn't.
It was a lot of stressful years.
A lot of tough times.
But I proved them wrong,
I proved myself right.
Everything I do in my
life is related to this.
I don't do nothing else if it's not
got to do with fighting, know what I mean?
That is why
All you've got to do is show up.
- Is that unhealthy?
I don't know, do I look unhealthy?
Take a look at this physique.
I'm in phenomenal shape, in body and mind.
To me what's unhealthy is
living an unhealthy life.
To me what's unhealthy is getting up
and going through the same day,
every day of your life 9 to 5
in an office, that's unhealthy.
That beats your mind.
I don't work, I love what I do.
And that's why I'm doing what I love.
That's why it's become a career for me
because I love it, I love what I do.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did you learn
from this video, what clips spoke the most
to you, and how are you going to apply it
immediately, somehow in your
life, or in your business.
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
Also, if you're leaving a comment within
the first few hours of
this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Louis Lopez from
The Better Men Project,
Louis, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, "Your One Word"
and doing the review on
your YouTube channel.
I really, really appreciate
the support, man,
and I'm so glad you enjoyed my book.
- [Narrator] If you
could describe yourself
with one word, what would it be?
- Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.